wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wogen sind immer
wieder alles neu beginnt
20 mal
guten morgen wir sind heute in der
bäckerei und ich treffe mmo wo sind wir
hier jetzt meinen backstube
da werden wir sehen und die brote
hergestellt
was machst du jetzt geplante weltcup-
super- in anderen teilen von deutschland
sagt man pfannkuchen oder berliner
berlin hat uns in bayern heißen sie
greifen
was ist es dass es aus butter zucker und
eier werden geklärt erst mal okay nach
stunden werden wir dann auf 180 grad
plus fällt das wetter muss man ganz
schnell drehen
platz und 30 sekunden und wie viele
karten verkauft sonntag 100 bis 150
stück fertig jetzt werden wir mit was
wir machen mit macht ihr auch welche mit
dem so ist eigentlich meine kraft
bisschen viel zu schade
so was kommt jetzt noch draufkommen
puderzucker drauf
und dann stehst du morgens auch wir
fangen um drei uhr in der frühe war um
12 fertig haben ok und wie lange habt
ihr den laden offen dann bis 18 uhr
doch was verkaufs am meisten bei deren
land am meisten verkaufen hier semmeln
und brezen sag mal wie kommt man dazu
fächer zu werden
ja ich wollte immer besser werden und so
eine ausbildung gemacht hat sich habe
der bäcker ausbildung kommt der
ausbildung habe ich auch gemacht und
dann hast du einfach gemacht ja das war
mein ziel und dann habe ich auch
gearbeitet und wie lange dauert die
ausbildung dauert drei jahre
der meisterschule dauert ein jahr so
sind die karten
danke dass du mir deine bäckerei gezeigt
und mit seinem frischen selbst gemachten
kraft denkt der plan richtig gut an